previously on TV sins maybe I'll dance
for you
oh she ever wanted was a home well I'll
certainly try to give her one this show
exists also main characters a classic
film fan cliche also also sleeping
during his girl Friday dad I'm excited
to watch this prequel to the good doctor
and how the death of his father turned
him to a life of healing this is gonna
be so uplifting since this show is
essentially five seasons of a kid with
the most severe case of mother issues
this side of Oedipus Rex I hope you
enjoy hearing the terms mother mommy or
mom because that's about every third
word Norman Freddie Highmore is honestly
quite good on the show and while no one
could ever replace Anthony Perkins
Highmore gives it as good a try as any
does that mean I'm not gonna laugh at
this and send this ridiculous emotional
outburst no no it does not time jumps at
a prequel feel like finding actual Oreos
and a package of hoodoos maybe I'm just
being ornery and a little dumb but
welcome to TV since there is no I and
Seafarer exactly like there is no I and
team except a little less inspirational
I'm not buying for a second that these
ropes would be keeping this luggage tied
down this bag here has absolutely
nothing keeping it from flying into the
windshield on the first heartbreak
simple elegant furnishings open space
light linen drapes fresh peonies fresh
what now Oh fresh peonies right the
flower because anyone without subtitles
just thought you said fresh panties
which for the record is also important
why would everything in this house still
be under plastic except this Bette which
for some reason is also completely made
with pillows and everything it's almost
like the show needed Norma to be able to
jump on it happily to show pure joy more
than the show needed any kind of
decorative consistency Norman how's the
peeping house the peeping Norman Norman
or me no mean are me your new watch
Annie when did you move here Norman
Bates where white house geez Oh creeps
were high school girls on TV always so
aggressively invasive when I was in high
school and the girls did stuff like a 10
class or work on homework or minded
their own business also don't you just
hate it when hot chicks randomly hit on
you at the bus stop you're in a
relationship with your mother chummy
brothers an older brother but he doesn't
live here just me and my mom exposition
through conversation with Mean Girls
Mean Girls position which was oddly
enough my college girlfriends favorite
role-playing position it involved clamps
and ice cubes it wasn't my favorite
taking your picture on someone else's
phone
not automatically make it appear in
contacts and it for sure won't type your
first name out I don't really play any
sports
what about track never do any running
not as a sport no track team tryouts are
today why don't you go talk to coach
carpenter after school I'll tell me
you're coming down no means no miss
Watson and I won't stand for your
non-consensual extra curricular
harassment does Keegan Connor Tracy
think she's on a CW show with this too
hot for teacher act because I don't put
up with that nonsense on my ante shows
ma'am we just bought a motel I mean how
do you expect me to get it up and
running without your house especially
since me just bought a zoo go ahead call
the police I go fishing with half of
them seems like Hugo root just gave
Norma the advantage she'll just call the
half of the police force that have no
interest in fishing with him the last
time the roofing was redone on this
place was a 50s let's talk about the
time setting for this show we firmly
established that we are in modern day
despite this being a prequel to a story
set in the 60s and yet the show uses
aesthetic choices from the original
timeline like the car the clothes or
even the choice of film for the opening
scene my point is that this show seems
to want to have it's 60s cake I need
some CW teen drama - I'm not buying it
I'm sure you would love to go but we're
in the middle of a lot of stuff psychic
but why do I have to be careful Norman
don't lose your temper with me I'm just
looking out for you what's the pitch for
this show let's do Hitchcockian serial
killer but with a melodramatic soap
opera style because this days of our
knives nonsense is really growing thin
for me this real-time sequence is the
equivalent of 24 just being the various
scenes when each of the characters have
to go to the bathroom it's being
exhausting and infuriating to have to
sit through oh my god you're so cute
I actually thought we were gonna go
steady here's the thing Bradley was at
school with Norman all day what in have
been easier to set this plan up with him
at school and we could have maybe
already talked Norma into letting him go
or at the very least understood this was
not a hot library date and just a hot
date I mean why is she surprised he
didn't get it look at the way he's
wearing that sweater with the shirt
underneath it just look Bradley
apparently even Norman freakin Bates
went to extravagantly program high
school parties attended by hundreds of
kids with a full sound setup in rooms
dedicated to blacklight shenanigans
these types of parties don't exist
anywhere but TV and movies right at my
high school we're lucky just to get six
of us around a campfire with 1/2 liter
of Mountain Dew to share sure enjoy your
life DJ disco ball laser lights and
multicolored orgy orbs based on what
I've researched and mostly just had
spoiled on Twitter by people who hate me
there appears to be more marijuana
storylines and 15 minutes of this show
and there was
all eight seasons of weeds also weeds
ran for eight seasons and since I was
just reminded of it Bates Motel gets to
pay this into these dumb [ __ ] leave
me here by yourself
oddly enough this is what happened on
Nicola Peltz when she and her friends
wandered onto the set of transformers
age of extinction and her punishment was
happy to star in that movie you like a
beautiful deep still lake in the middle
of a concrete world sure that lake grows
up to skin people alive and where it is
clothing the show better be careful
because if I've learned anything from
the neverending Joker hot takes you
aren't allowed to give empathy to
Psychopaths and this one is based on one
of the sickest serial killers to ever
live he's not even completely fictional
discount Vincent D'Onofrio throws this
table to the side knocking this chair to
the ground but little did he know it's a
magically resetting table not two
seconds later it's back at its original
position with the chair still upright
man on most shows when teenagers sneak
out they get grounded but on Bates Motel
the mom gets attacked and almost killed
by bump Johnson who is gonna book a room
in the murder motel based on psycho 2
and psycho 3 quite a few people we're
gonna take all the bed linens from every
motel room and I'm gonna use it to soak
this all up wasn't using all the towels
from every motel room make more sense
here you are and Here I am and he's not
gonna win this one the fact that this
show works at all deserves us in off and
the performance of Vera Farmiga ups that
ante quite a bit so I'm feeling a bit
generous here
Vanessa pulled the whole carpet sure but
if that much blood soaked through in the
few seconds he was sitting there how is
there not an orgy of evidence all the
way down those stairs you dragged him
down
earlier not to mention you have no idea
how he got here or if he told anyone
where he's going plus the police are
about to conveniently stop by for
maximum tension all I'm saying is
covering up a dead person is hard and I
feel like the rest of the show should be
the Bates family dealing with their new
life in prison so I wanna make sure
everything was all right here we didn't
know anybody
hey it's Nestor Carbonell he's the only
actor whose performances are 100%
eyebrow and loading oh yeah what oh
sorry about that
I imagine under the dome here did a few
takes of this line so I'm super curious
to see how bad the other ones work nice
man J : probably not the most
appropriate thing to say to people you
just met as you X in a bathroom but you
do you Richard Alpert really I'm sure
after his mom had him rip up the carpet
in several different hotel rooms because
of a single blood patch that they
completely missed this very obvious
blood spatter on his white sneaker tip
come on me em you could have still had
your visible representation of guilt is
carried into a public place cliche
without making them seen this
Oh make sure you're done this is yet
another attractive girl going out of her
way to talk to this guy I guess I wasn't
weird and introverted enough in high
school to get this kind of attention so
I'm jealous are you
okay more people asked Norman if he's
okay normal weird etc in the first 40
minutes of this series than anyone would
ever do to anyone else we know he's
going to turn into a serial killer but
no one else does the writers of this
show don't seem to understand that
though this public notice is very
helpful I'm pretty sure it should have a
date on it beyond just Wednesday there
are actually quite a few of those that
happen through the year you know when
you move more and it was like I gave you
a second chance
skip roll commercials we're going to
send you to a place where people are so
far out they have wings this property
has been in my family for over a century
look I'm sorry I ruined your evening but
I mean you could've seriously screwed
things up for me you sure yeah okay
she's got the crazy eyes
dude the eyes they're crazy mother